like you just go airbnb now right oh
yeah yeah yeah
because you know what i started to think
about dude you know what i really
started to think about
would you if someone was like hey man
use mattress for sale would you be like
i'm not buying that [ __ ] mattress
never do you know in a hotel that's all
they're all used it's you're sleeping on
other people's [ __ ] bets yeah you ever
seen when they do like the black lights
dude i brought one oh you did so i did a
show
i did a show where they were like you
travel one of the things we want you to
do is bring a
black light to your room the black light
so the curtains are gross but the
bathroom walls
it's like people are coming and just
throwing it just busting just [ __ ]
but just like
throwing it at the wall i'm like
shooting ropes
dude but i've never been that excited in
a hotel bathroom to [ __ ] shoot
i'm jumping over the sink yeah the the
dirtiest thing is the phones and the
remote controls
nobody thinks about that but they never
watch the remotes or the phones
i got everyone's [ __ ] grimy hands
that they're doing god's nose why
oh you know what [ __ ] in there and then
picking up the phone like hey how's it
going baby you don't
send me a water yeah yeah i i need more
towels
and then you're picking up the phone
they don't clean those the i don't [ __ ]
with hotels anymore no you can't thank
god
i'm at a level now right i don't thank
god i don't have to do hotels
see i don't mind a hotel man but a nice
hotel
but if you're like if the black light is
like
look if you're staying in a place where
people are jerking off in the mirror
over the sink where you brush your teeth
yeah
here's the thing papa they're doing it
even in four seasons though
that's just especially in four seasons
yeah dude the freaks of four seasons the
white rich freaks in there they're just
used to having people clean up for
yeah or it's like the the celebrity
who's staying there
you know dude i stayed in a hotel once
in atlanta right
and this is again back before i was
staying in places where this wouldn't
happen
and i sat down and had like a living
room and a in a bedroom and i was like
oh that's fancy this yeah and you know
what i mean
and so i sat down on the couch and i was
wearing shorts not too often am i
wearing shorts
b i've never seen the insurance there's
a reason do you want have you ever seen
how pale my
legs are yeah they're pale and it's thin
right yeah yeah
dainty ankles so i sat down on the couch
and i felt like a jab in my leg and my
hamstring and i was like what the hell
tell me it was a needle
my man it was a someone had picked
the toenail off their big toe and stuck
it in the couch so it was sticking
straight out oh wow
so and i and it jabbed the back of my
leg
now i didn't take it out of the couch
because i was like if this happened to
me
it's gonna have to pay for it yeah yeah
but it was one of the grossest that it
was right around the time where i was
like
i'm picking my own hotel from here on
out yeah yeah it's tough
i think the only hotel stands hotel emma
in
san antonio that's my favorite hotel
outside batman especially
like pandemic air when i was torn down
pandemic hotels were such a bummer
yeah there's no room service they they
cut down the staff
everybody's depressed everybody's in
masks so i'm just like oh yeah and
they're like if you could wash your own
towels you're like [ __ ]
oh they don't clean the room nobody's
cleaning the room [ __ ] this yeah yeah
yeah but some of the airbnb is getting a
little dicey like we got one in austin
there's i traveled like a squad there's
like eight of us so we got one in austin
uh and pictures looked sick but dude it
was straight up somebody's
somebody straight up family home dude
there was the kids money in the piggy
bank no yeah and
my my where the pic so i the one thing
about those houses i don't like
if if you have your family pictures on
the wall i can't [ __ ] with that i can't
be in somebody's house like but they it
was like
they just and it was these doctors we
found these like indian doctors and
their whole family's there like
it's six kids or whatever so there's all
these rooms but it's all their kids
stuff is in there so that means like
hey kids someone booked it for next
weekend so we gotta get our [ __ ]
now here's the thing we gotta get our
[ __ ] and go to the guest room
up right there so no it specifically
said do not go to the
the guest room and i'm like why the [ __ ]
why would they care if we go to the
guest room
well that's because all of them move
there while we're there so it was like
houses here detached
guest house and they're all in the guest
house so they're
doing their thing like looking at us no
no no
sometimes yeah so the actual homeowners
were staying in the backyard yeah
chilling no
no first of all again postmates
deliveries and [ __ ] we're like what are
you what's happening right now
i i i don't know about you man but i
don't think that i could go back
and live in my house because first of
all i don't know what people are doing
in my kids beds that's what's weird like
you got comics sleeping in your kid's
bed and you left your kid left this
piggy bank
and then the kids like like they had
their medications still in the drawers
and [ __ ] so obviously
i'm going through all the medications
like is there anything good in here
there's any drugs you know it's funny by
the way
um so you know i've known joe diaz for a
long time
and he and i when we were doing drugs
and didn't have any money we used to
leave ious in my son's piggy bank
and so years later when we i finally
went through there i'm like let's see
how much money you got
i found like four hundred dollars in
ious for me
it was like i owe you 20 bucks dog yeah
sorry
sorry dog i needed some blow dog yeah
he was like what are these like where
the [ __ ] this money you might want to
keep that one
that's 60 bucks from uncle joey there
uncle joey was on a bender man
used your cash do you know one time when
jacob was like
two and joey was used to stay at my
house a bunch
jacob used to love things that made
noises sure and he liked the maracas
they needed to walk around with maracas
in his little underwear he'd watch
blue's clues and go yeah
and so one day i was in the kitchen and
he was uh i heard him
and i was like what is going on and i
walked out there and he had two little
baggies of coke that made
noise that had fallen out of somebody's
pocket probably joey's
stayed at the house
[Laughter]
and i was like hey buddy hey buddy hey
buddy hey bud let's not open those
yeah that's not that's not kool-aid papa
why don't you go ahead and hand those
yeah
[ __ ] crazy yeah have you talked to
joey since he's been out
oh yeah jersey hell yeah he's happy is
he happy
he's happier than i've he he's not very
poor though right he's
because of the covetous he's still
worried about covington no it's not that
it's not he just want a break it's not
that either i think he
is trying to figure out how much he
wants to tour ever again
i think that's it you know man that'd be
taking a break though technically right
like you're going to kind of stop
stopping from doing it all together so
you know he used to keep this both of us
he used to just keep a notebook every
time you went on stage
and what the jokes you did how long you
did it where you performed what you
think worked and didn't work
and joey would set a goal for himself
monthly gigs
and i i think monthly gigs for a while
there
he was setting the goal for 45 cents a
month
40 45 cents a month that's including the
spots at the store or wherever
45 sets a month whether it's 10 15 an
hour
just counting those 45 sets yeah a total
45 mics right
and he did that and not only that dude
you know he was doing at a time where he
didn't have a car
people used to tell me all the time i
think there's like five joe diaz's
because i see one walking down the
street
in every part of this city yeah and if
you add that
up you know he was saying the other day
he was like i've just
i'm burnt i've just done it so much
and that year off the year off man made
a lot of us
rethink and i didn't take a year i
didn't take a full year off yeah but
still it forced us to be like hold up
hold up man
what am i doing you guys are out of your
mind yeah you you i know you want to
book me four weeks a month but
what it's yeah and it's a lot of
diminishing if you have kids
like tom segura told me like you know he
because i
i you know i think it comes out two
beers one cave it's me and sagura
and i'm like dude you're a guy like i
never saw you around like the store
all the time like the other guys like i
come from the joe rogan
blueprint where it's like set set set
set sets and i was known as like a
stagehound where
if there was an open mic i'm there man
just call me uh
i'm your guy so i was doing four or five
sets every night monday through thursday
then
friday on tour so full hour two shows
friday two show saturday back home
sunday back to the race
on monday and i was like tom you weren't
like that he's like well when i was
younger i was he's like but dude
as you do it like i build my hour on the
road man i'm
you have kids dude so i'm not i'm not
out at night dude if i am you know every
once in a while i'd come out and you
guys would see me but
i'm building the hour on the road and
that's what joe coy did it never made
sense to my god they're just not working
no they
are but they're also present in their
kids lives that's
you know so a lot of
people like the generation of comics
before me
i mean after me i've heard a lot of them
say
recently because we look man i was the
same way i was raising kids
so i wasn't hanging out at the store no
i was going to do my and i'm a grown-up
bro
what am i hanging out that nothing good
is happening from hanging out
maybe a couple chats with some of the
guys my hangouts here yeah yeah and that
green room for
15 minutes beforehand and messing around
and talking about gravity is great
but if you're there till two in the
morning nothing good is coming out of
that especially you have kids you gotta
be up at six what were you doing yeah
man it
and it's again i'm taking two hours out
of their lives
so i can talk to whoever the [ __ ] about
your set
i don't think so yeah and so i i had a
bunch of comics they were like yeah we
always thought you were just kind of
aloof no and i was like no
and they said as we got older we
realized that you just had
[ __ ] to do your priorities dude i had
three kids sitting at the house
commitments yeah yeah so it but but
hashtag good day you bet but
i'm with you writing on the road also
for me
is way better because you're writing in
front of
i don't want to i don't want to make it
sound like um
the comedy store crowds aren't the real
crowds but they're not the crowds you're
performing in front of
on the road well the road is a little
bit of a home game right
yeah yeah you have more leeway and but
at the common store especially
you know prior to it kind of blowing up
everybody going their own way
it was like you couldn't do new material
because your
people are there to see if it's an
all-star game yeah so it's not like
you'd be like i'm gonna do
10 minutes of new material hopefully it
works out in front of this crowd who
you know joe rogan's the headliner and
joey diaz is there and
segura and you and you know dalia and
these monsters it's like oh i'm not
gonna do 10 minutes of new material
because then
people are going to walk out i'm like
jesus christ man you see rogan with the
greatest thing
i see joey diaz joshua you know
[ __ ] mark marin you know jaisal nick
and all these monsters then
see shop dude you see his new [ __ ] dude
so it's like
i know to get better you have to do new
[ __ ] but i found myself
doing the same set that i knew worked
because i had to because
i had to pass that test because there's
all these monsters there but that's the
trap dude that's the comedy trap
so the comedy trap is making okay
so when you hop on stage especially i
mean you still
as far as comedy goes you're still young
for sure six years
so for for you every every set should
still be
how am i getting better yep right how am
i getting better
and and so the mistake is also feeding
the ego trying to feed the ego
at the same time as trying to get better
and those two a lot of times don't align
but now
throw into that feeding the ego but then
also
performing a standard where you can
compete with those monsters but that's a
part of that's
that's what i mean it's the ego but it's
all it's an ego but it's also
it for me it's different right because
you know
people are going to come in with these
assumptions already so it's
feeding the ego then obviously checking
that box but here's the deal man
ultimately to feed the ego ultimately
to compete with the people you want to
compete with
yep you have to take those risks fail
yes
you have to get on stage in front of
people who don't know you correct you
have to play
constant away games yeah to go oh this
actually is funny yeah
this isn't just funny because they know
who i am yep this is funny
right and so the the key for that is
like when you go
going up in front of rogan and those
guys where you're like well i want to
[ __ ] kill two because i know they're
ganu
but to ultimately to really kill you
have to eat [ __ ] for a while 100
you know what i mean 100 and so like
it's it's
it's fascinating like when you see
people start to take the curve
of like oh i really don't care what
they're thinking
i just want to do what i do and get
better you know who's on that curve
right now
your girl annie letterman so
i think for a long time she's great
great dude and for a long time
i think she had an idea of who she was
and she tried to play
into that idea and right now she's sure
of who she is
and that kind of thing that you saw
three years ago you're like i think
that's funny
but i wish it was really is full 100
percent
but she was taking risks back like i
remember seeing her like in the meeting
she'd be like the last one to go it'd be
like midnight she's like where the [ __ ]
you guys go yeah
we were like winding out she was just
doing work but right now
those risks are coming with such extreme
confidence
and i don't give a [ __ ] what you think
yep i'm trying to find what makes me
better
and like i watched her last night and i
could see her she was just
thinking at the store thinking and
trying to find stuff
but it was so authentic it was watchable
it was like yeah this
is somebody oh yeah she's gonna be
finding what yeah so
are you getting up a bunch of nashville
yeah man let's
face it shopping for car and home
insurance is complicated you could spend
days looking up hundreds of providers
scrolling through thousands of policy
options
and then also you got to enter in your
email or your phone number and you're
getting spammed
and blown up by super sellers they're
just blown up your phone or emails
it's not cool man even then it's hard to
know if you're getting the best pricing
coverage
for whatever you're looking for that's
where the zebra can help you the zebra
is the nation's leading insurance
comparison site
for car and home insurance in other
words they do the shopping for
you just five minutes you can compare
quotes for
every major insurance provider side by
side for
free all from one independent
marketplace the zebra appears people
with insurance company that's right for
them
delivering quotes with the coverage they
need all right
saving you an average of 922
on home and car insurance combined shop
car insurance without shopping around
get all your options in one place for
free by visiting
thezebra.com fighter that's the
zebra.com
fighter let's take a break from chat
with my boy josh wolf because guess what
man it's 2020 and mental health is
finally a thing
there's so many people that are
struggling right now and they're not
feeling like their normal selves right
and you know what helps with that
therapy not talking to your friends
around the work place
not talking face timing with your man or
whatever it is
i'm talking about real licensed
professionals who are going to help you
get
in the right place that you're looking
to get that's where better help
is here for you it's a customized online
therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to but we can
also do that
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy you can start communicating with
your therapist in under 48 hours
join the millions of people who are
seeing what therapy is really about see
if it's for you
because you are your greatest asset and
this episode
of firing the kid with josh wuff is
brought to you by better help
and you listeners and viewers the fire
and kid listeners
and viewers get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com
fighter that's dot com slash fighter
are you getting up a bunch of nashville
yeah man
yeah yeah uh zanies and
and listen dude you know nashville has
been such a
[ __ ] great move for me you know
ellen you've been la for a hot second
yeah dude and it started to take a
little piece of me
that i didn't realize until i got to
nashville how so
man here's my thing you wouldn't be
nashville ready or bangkok
ready if you didn't go through the
trials and tribulations of the
machine that is l.a yeah la makes
diamonds
yes everyone who shits on it now it's
like you couldn't handle the pressure
you could it's a dude we're sharks out
here man
yeah that's the thing if we swim no one
stops swimming
but you stopped swimming you moved to
texas or nashville
but it's different when you're you or
rogan or sagura or these other guys are
tim diller and these other guys who
moved because we're theo
because yeah you guys made it here yeah
he had a career and then you went out
there it's different
yeah and you know what for me i was
ready
for it out there because look man
there's a
the last little bit of something that i
felt like i
didn't have here for example man
you know what i never played guitar on
stage here because i was just worried
about
what other people were gonna get the
store yeah man i and i'll tell you
something i love
because people are like yeah because
it's considered like almost a hacky
gig without a doubt and but that
man the biggest mistake any of us make
is like do i like it then it shouldn't
matter one [ __ ]
what somebody because you know what say
you were like man i hate the guitar
guess who's not paying tickets to come
to see me
you yeah so why you know what i mean
those people aren't gonna pay anyway
yeah and so and i always like i still do
an
hour of stand up and then like 15 or 20
minutes on the guitar
do whatever the [ __ ] you want it's
you're saying you weren't comfortable
out here i wasn't comfortable doing it
and
now you bearing katara and you sell 50
more tickets buddy
anywhere and it is so much [ __ ] fun
and at the end of the day man
at the end of the day i want to have fun
when i'm on stage
i don't want to have fun i think there's
a line of having fun then also making
sure that the crowd digs it too because
it's like oh i like the whatever play
the harmonica but when you get out that
harmonica
a hundred people leave probably quit
playing the [ __ ] harmonica dude i'm
not i don't know how much you like yeah
i would never bring out the
guitar in front of mark maron's crowd
but my crowd
my crowd is people who are just out to
have a [ __ ] good time
that's a home game right a home game yep
home game
but like tonight i'm gonna bring the
guitar to supernova just to see
what happens yeah and uh and i'm from
i'm not i'm gonna
stop apologizing in my mind for it
because at the end of the day
yo dude i've run through uh
i've done a ton of stand up i've done a
ton of material yeah ten thousand
dollars
and this is now what's making it extra
fun for me so i'm gonna keep [ __ ]
doing it
because you went to nashville you felt
like the the pressure different
different pressure out there
not pressure like that's the thing too i
was putting pressure on myself out here
that i did not need to do
i [ __ ] dude look i know who i am i know
who i'm not
and you know what at this point my
career i'm a good [ __ ] comment yeah
and so i don't need to prove myself
to anybody sure anymore yep now
what how how do i do this so i still
have fun doing it i've been doing that
with joe joe's burnout i think if that
guitar
joey yeah i think that's guitar no no
he's not
no he's an animal but i think the guitar
extended has extended my life yeah dude
it's just and it's me what's weird is
all you older those are [ __ ] dope
those are so sick right proud of you
yeah thanks man
first time i've seen without pumas thank
god not that there's anything wrong with
pumas but those are dope yeah thank you
but i think uh
all you older heads you know especially
you know all you guys are my
you know peers like a lot of common
theme and i'm not going to mention names
that
a lot of people are like yeah just burnt
out yeah i'm just you know you've been
doing it whatever six years but you know
i've been doing
14 15 20. it's like dude i'm just sick
of the hustle yeah
and then and they're crushing it too but
they're like yeah and i'm like but dude
you're [ __ ] you're
an 80 grand a weekend guy like i know
dude i'm just [ __ ] i'm tired man
yeah which i get i i promise you you
know what i don't do anymore
with the guitar now because i'm looking
forward to it so much and you know what
else i do
almost every set well for sure people
who come see me know
when you come see my friday early show
and late show
saturday early show late show those are
different shows you're watching four
different shows yeah
so i have people come to my early shows
and late shows because they know
i'm not going to repeat a joke i might
if there's like 15 minutes i'm working
on that's what i'll repeat yeah
try to figure it out i'm there dude to
have fun
what's fun for me just to keep
experimenting and finding
i've been reinvigorated with that move
it's been [ __ ] fantastic and like i
said it's
made me love stand-up again so you only
getting up in
at zany's or the spots in nashville just
zanny's because
just like you were saying with segura
and joe i ride on the road
you know what i mean i i [ __ ] about on
the road
at least 10 or 15 minutes of show i just
kind of start
riffing and i'm like what what can we
find
is it is it tough then i'd love saying
but tough at zany because zany's isn't
like the store where it's a comic store
like zanny's the headliners
so the weekends thursday friday saturday
sunday that's the headliners are there
it's a headliner club
well mondays is that you can come on and
do whatever material
and tuesdays if they haven't booked
anybody so sometimes it's mondays and
tuesdays sometimes what
savage is doing tuesdays well tuesdays
you do that open
is also an open mic okay but sometimes
someone will come in and book a tuesday
i think the last two tuesdays if they're
on tour
last week was joe was george lopez
two weeks before that louis c.k super
road dog so they see luke
louis ck set i was out of town [ __ ] i
wouldn't
see that i was super curious the one guy
would stop whatever i'm doing go see so
what they're
only a few i would do that they said
that that his new material is
top five dude for you top five lucy k
[ __ ] yes
monster are you the top five ever or top
five
just right now definitely top five
right now yeah but you know there's
conversation for top five ever yeah
you know who i think gets left out of
that top five uh is patrice o'neill
and i don't know i don't know how that
he passed away so like he's not
current with the new guys but when you
when you think of all time
oh for sure patrice [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] he was so casually monster good
at talking about [ __ ] that nobody else
yep would say burrs a little bit i mean
when they came up they're cut from the
same clock yeah
i would say burr's number one right now
i you i don't know that you are you
just it's just pure pound for pound you
know when we did so we did a roast of of
david ortiz
a couple years back when he was um
retiring
and i was setting it up and i asked burr
i go you won't come do it and he was
like yeah i'll come do it
and so the night before a bunch of us
we're going to practice our roast that
laugh boston
and i go you want to practice your roast
he was like nah he was like i think i
got it
and i was like
i was like oh okay and he goes i'm just
going to try something it's like asking
ken griff you want to you want to take
your face
like no [ __ ] what bottom bracket i'm
pretty good yeah
now [ __ ] i'll show up to the game dude
i did take bp
with junior's bat oh with his bat but
he's not there
no we're out there in the kingdom i was
touring with larry the cable guy
and and we went to take bp and griff
when when uh
the ken griffey jr when cable guy went
up there he was like uh
he was like you want to swing them up by
bat and kevin was like yeah
and so he said can my can my guy take a
couple of swings and he was like
yeah i guess you know he kissed my back
yeah he was he was psyched about him he
was yeah i don't want this to be
touching my [ __ ] back yes man yo
first of all it was like
i was like this is a little heavier than
i thought but to swing with that bat
like the ken griffey bad the sweetest
swing of all time
i almost broke my beverly his logo oh
come on come on
donkey we watched the all-star game or
the home run derby this past weekend i
did did you
yeah i did i i i don't miss that [ __ ] i
love it the whole thing is important
for the most boring [ __ ] it's getting
better because they do like a bracket
system now and like the big boys do
compete in it but
but you but your boy chin the uh otario
what's the name
the what's his name ohtani ohtani what's
the atari
my bad yeah like he was the favorite
going into it and he hit
i think he set the record for he had
five over 500 yards
it's in course 500 feet yeah 500 feet
yeah he hit five of them but he didn't
do well so it kind of took the sales out
of the win out of the sales yeah because
everyone's just
dude he you don't realize how famous he
is yeah he's by far the most famous guy
in baseball
like everyone else got up like alonzo
who's the
homer and king he's a monster i think
he's won uh
three years in a row whatever if you
don't include the pandemic that off
but he's a monster and like they cheered
for him even the rockies guy they
cheerful
dude when he got up it was like the
beatles he's so [ __ ] famous he has
an entire other part of the world yeah
rooting for him yeah that's fine this is
what i'm saying in america dude like
i know i'll see japan's used to travel
when suzuki used to travel jammed dude
he's bigger than all them
uh
yes he also threw a hundred mile per
hour that's pretty crazy
dude he pitched and then hit have you
ever stood about
he normal is he a giant dude yes he's
[ __ ] how big is he speaking of giant
dudes
have you put on 49 pounds what's up dog
you don't see me in a while i've been
lifting man
well first of all you have your prison
shirt on nice to see you
is that all you're wearing now as your
prison joints dude 6'4
every bit of it too 203 pounds 203 64
now his team sucks [ __ ] but he's a good
[ __ ] player
have you ever stood in the box with a
hundred never okay so i still have
no desire to either when i was in high
school i stood in the box with a dude
named mark wohler mark waller pitched
for the braves he actually
lost the world series uh to the yankees
well lost but gave up a home run that
that sucks and so that sucks that's what
he's known for i know
it's a lot of work he was throwing in
high school was probably throwing
not pumping 93-94 and we were using
aluminum bats and we faced them in april
so in massachusetts it was cold and none
of us wanted the bat to touch the ball
you know that feeling so there were
there were people on my guys on my team
who were just not even swinging and our
coach was like are you guys not going to
swing we were like nah nah we're good
we're 100 not gonna switch it's negative
yeah yeah anyways
i i um but that ball gets on you
that's why like what i think hitting a
baseball is the hardest thing to do in
any production
what's harder hitting a a baseball like
a game-winning home run
in the major leagues or a penalty kick
being a goalie stopping at
like did you watch england versus i did
italy and when they went to penalty
kicks i'm like [ __ ] dude
now granted italy has the best goalie in
the world right he's like he won the mvp
of the world cup the euro cup
but uh not the world cup the euro cup
but
you know he has a tough [ __ ] to stop
those [ __ ] kicks and he did pretty
[ __ ] well obviously they won
yeah but i was i've seen my head what
would be tougher that
at that level or hitting a home run off
like nolan ryan back in his head all
right so let me
for baseball let's start with this
the goal is to square up a round ball
on a round bat sure so think about
how big this area that is on the bat
it's like this
but think of the air the strike zone
area so you're not like
you're squaring up like the strike zone
is not like [ __ ] six by six okay okay
so let's just talk about even if i just
lob it to you
i'm not the [ __ ] out of it but you're
squaring it up
is completely different sure all right
so you're squaring to hit that square
on top of that i am 60 feet away from
you
yep now if you google how fast does a 95
mile an hour
fastball get on top of you things flying
so you got to make
and not only that dude right here
you have to tell me what pitch is coming
for sure so
these guys some junk they can read
whether your hand is here yep
or here whether your hand arm slot
all of that is happening in real time
and then here but my problem was this
again the strike zone
was slider and fastball look the same
the only difference is is that right
about there to where the end of the
table is
the slider starts to move for sure i
have to be able to decipher that with my
[ __ ] eyes yep and hit something at
that point that i think is going to be
moving 95 minutes that's
all you do that's all you all you do is
see those pictures non-stop but you stop
but now think if you're that [ __ ]
goalie yeah have you ever seen a real
soccer goalie yeah like like
the the the actual goal yeah it's huge
yeah but those dudes
and they're like and they're like
[ __ ] so you and then homeboy is
flying like the best percent the best
kicker in the not good
but yeah but even baseball is [ __ ]
terrible you get three out of 10 you're
in the hall of fame
but if dude with penalty kicks at that
level you have [ __ ]
kane the guy like all he does is
specialize in kicking the [ __ ] ball
yeah like a lot of it's just guess work
they like dive one way it's 100 guess
work on those
i i also i didn't realize how fast those
soccer balls are moving dude
yo those are ronaldo or messi's kicking
that [ __ ] thing
what is your tell me what you think is
the one job in professional sports the
one position
and i don't mind is that you wouldn't
want to have and mine would be hockey
goalie
i don't care how many pads you got on me
that would suck to get hit by but you
got all that
[ __ ] on and then again your bait you
know they they can only go through your
legs right here you know they like stop
that and they're pretty flexible
the shittiest job to be a catcher like
you're just on your knees like a
jackass the whole time but the the word
the toughest job in professional sports
is uh nfl quarterback hands down
toughest job without a doubt
for that you have to come but as far as
like the most like difficult
one of those goalies during the penalty
kick and let's say it's the world cup
are you [ __ ] me dude yeah because
you know if you let one go through
somebody from that country oh dude don't
throw urine bombs on you well dude in
england the the three penalty kickers
and one was like this poor kitty 17 but
they're they're
they're black guys the the racism they
got after this is it is
nuts nuts yo it's crazy to me the
lengths that soccer fans will go
to show they're unhappy like the most
die hard especially in england dude
like that's their religion you read
articles about how they were throwing
like fans throw urine balloons at each
other hell yeah if i was at a red sox
game
and a yankee fan was like [ __ ] yo and
they started
throwing [ __ ] piss i'm like dude
what's what's wrong
what the what are we doing it's a
baseball baseball game bro
baseball we're out at the park like
first of all
how why are you sticking your dick in a
balloon it's very strange it's very
you're a loser yeah you've got something
put your work down
i have to tell you something else just
the idea and i don't know why i'm just
thinking about but just
holding a warm balloon like if it's my
ear and i don't give a [ __ ] no dude
i'm not it's all weird hold on you'll be
a real loser fill up balloon with piss
the first because you're just this team
lost yeah what's wrong with you
what went wrong where did your parents
[ __ ] up dude if my kids are doing that i
failed as a dad
without a doubt if their first thought
is let's lob you dude if i bring my son
to the rams game when he's 18
and he's like hold on i got these
balloons i'm gonna throw out the [ __ ]
patriots i'm like
what are they filled with he's like this
i'm like [ __ ] dude
i want to apologize to you man because i
[ __ ] up as a dad what happened what
did i do
what i did i gave you too much yeah what
happened was i not hard where did i go
wrong yeah yeah
i should have hit you more those who do
you think okay
so soccer fans obviously the the
weirdest in that way but as far as
american sports fans who do you think
what fan base do you think is the
the most like off kilter ah [ __ ] that's
a good question
ufc fans are pretty hardcore because
they want to see blood it's like
gladiator
so then i think maybe i'm jaded because
i come from that world i've
i've experienced it walking through the
tunnel like rip his head off
i hope you die like percentage of them
what poorly [ __ ] yeah what percentage
of the fans
are that and what 99
all right okay yeah all right now i i
don't know because you were talking
about like the red sox was yankees yeah
like
the [ __ ] not i don't know what the
ufc fans
like raiders versus broncos like that's
interesting raiders chargers
raised chargers but now that they're in
vegas that that kind of goes away but
yeah
like chiefs raiders or like chiefs
broncos it gets pretty dicey man
the ufc fans and by the way the the
i think by the way conor mcgregor i
think
done he's i think when i that he looks
like ronda rousey to me when he was
leading up to this fight by the way
that's why she supported him this
particular fight was the first time i
watching his interviews i'm not great at
a lot of things but as
comics you know what one thing i think
we're good at because we see people a
lot is reading them 100
yeah i agree 100 with that and so when i
saw this present i was like ah [ __ ] i'm
like even i was like i'm not buying this
i was like he doesn't believe a single
no he's a he was a version of his
of his old self and i he was doing lost
yeah he was doing he was impersonation
of himself correct
and that old conor is gone so when i
watch sound like ah dude this is an
imitation of what you used to be
this ain't going to go well i so when i
used to watch him
and as somebody who came from some with
no money
i was like oh i recognize this hunger i
recognize this
i'm going to [ __ ] eat you for what
you you're standing in front of what i
want
and it seemed real to me like what he
was saying
he believed all of it and it was it was
witty and it was like swag was
real and just the like the how witty was
with his comebacks and
remember with jeremy stevens the classic
liner who the [ __ ] this guy
like ruined jeremy stevens career like
yeah just yeah
i mean it was he was uncanny but then
now here's what i was thinking about
this last night i couldn't sleep last
night for whatever reason i was thinking
about this
you think about our podcast today yeah i
was yeah but no uh
i was thinking about this like
fighting's the only sport where guys get
paid and they get worse
because in basketball like lebron signs
a
gillian dollar deal or dame lillard or
you name anybody
any of these big name players they send
deals and then they feel the pressure to
perform and they
they [ __ ] get better like like the
greek freak signs the maximum deal and
then he puts on and tries to win a
championship
and they they when they get money they
get better in other sports
like aaron judge signs a deal or [ __ ]
uh homeboy the pitcher
you know these like trout and they get
better because they're like oh you paid
us all this money i go perform
i can bring a championship to the city
and finally get paid and they're like oh
i'm good and they like
they get worse but you know what's crazy
besides floyd mayweather but other than
that it's like they get worse
i i i i and i thought conor was gonna be
different and i bet you there's some
in football some people get paid and
take a step back a little bit to kind of
you know preserve their careers maybe
but not really like you look at like
aaron rodgers you sign those
deals you're like tom brady it's like
like tom brady has all the money but by
the way that's the difference
never been more hungry so brady that's a
great example and even guys like tiger
woods
so for me when you look at brady in
tiger woods
and jordan and all these guys you know
what drove them legacy
i want them yeah they got the money like
cool check all right let's keep going i
want to be the
[ __ ] best and in fighting in mma it's
not that way but connor
like when i watch this and someone was
like he's fighting for his legacy i'm
like if he is he doesn't give a [ __ ] i
agree he doesn't give a [ __ ]
because you know what honestly the
difference between like
golf and whatever basketball is you're
not getting punched in the face
mm-hmm yeah right so i might just go to
work if i sell my whiskey and i'm making
600 million dollars and you're like hey
you want to get punched in the face
tomorrow i'm like
no no dude i'm [ __ ] good with getting
down because i saw my whiskey
not here i swallowed my whiskey yeah why
would i get punched in the face
schultz made this comparison you know
obviously schultz doesn't know the fight
game
and i thought it was interesting and he
has no ground to stand on he's like dude
i don't know this but
this is what i think is going on is he's
basically forced to take these fights
because let's say he's making 20 30
million dollar fight
it's like you look at him you're like do
you have 400 million why are you taking
what like what the [ __ ] you're doing
he's like i think
he sold his whiskey but the stipulation
sound that whiskey is you have to fight
this many times
you can't just sell the whisk and dip
the [ __ ] out and at first i was like
jesus christ schultz but then i was like
it's not a bad conspiracy like like i
mean
they were like hey we're we're gonna buy
you out and you get 400 million and do
whatever you want
and i'm sure you know dana's involved
that deal stuff like that but
you got to fight this guy you got to
fight this many times a year
and the manny pacquiao fight has to go
down because the
the more you're in the spotlight the
more whiskey we sell you can't just sell
your whiskey and dip the [ __ ] out
which to all of us common people are
like dude just
[ __ ] quit fighting yeah you got all
the money in the world
he's like no i do but basically signed a
deal with the devil because now
i don't feel like fighting and i'm
fighting these [ __ ] savages
but this is the deal that i signed now
again there is
no there's no proof of any of this but
when schultz said them like that
it's not a bad conspiracy my man i i
think
also and there's nothing worse when
comics give their take on fighting when
they have no [ __ ] clue what they're
talking
about but with schultz he's he's he's
getting more into it he's
close with izzy and you know he's a very
smart guy and
he's following the sport and so his
conspiracy and his view on them like
that's not a far-fetched idea dude
i think you overlook a couple things on
that and i i don't know what the [ __ ] do
i know
but even though he's not worried about
his legacy or maybe he is but not as
much as he should be
his ego is intermittent
ego is what got into the dance yes and
that doesn't go away
no but but to me his ego which is the
same
is no which used to match up with his
drive for this
they're not equal anymore so his he's
still saying what he thinks he's
supposed to say
and i don't think he wants the big thing
for him is i don't think he wants
the last thing for us to see is these
last two fights
agree he that's why i think you'll find
a nate diaz or something somebody where
he's got a chance next year
yeah yeah yeah sure but when you were
watching that first round because when i
heard him talk about i was punching him
and i was i was like
what were you maybe i was watching the
wrong i went on a long rant about this
on below the belt
is he's not living reality his team's
not living in reality and us as
conor mcgregor fans we're not living in
reality like we gotta
look at what's really going on he's won
one fight in five years
one fight in five years how much is real
how much is that real
so real especially at his level yeah
because even khabib
uh did an interview i forget who he did
with but they asked him about retiring
if he'd fight gsb or if he'd come out
and fight does emporia
and he goes i can't train at the level i
i don't have the desire to train at the
level that i would need to to compete
with those guys
and when he said that and you're talking
about he's regarded as the best
you know probably the best of all time
he just didn't go on the josh thompson
made a great point where
he would be considered the greatest of
all time but he didn't go on a long
enough run because he retired at 29.00
but if you stick around he'd be by far
the greatest of all time but when khabib
who's a [ __ ] animal in that training
room goes
i don't have the desire to do to do what
it takes to compete with those guys on a
regular basis i don't want to do that
anymore
when he says that and then conor thinks
he can take
years off or a year off and then jump in
there with the best 155
on the planet yeah we're on this transom
because we all came up with the connor
come up and it was especially the most
special time in sport
maybe in sports of all time is so
[ __ ] special and
we're i'm so grateful that for connor
for doing that but we're still
in that right phase that those days are
over man
you you ca mma is not that sport we can
take that time off
take all that time off do get rich as
[ __ ] and then come back and compete with
the best guys
especially at his a and he's not old but
he's on the tail end of that athletic
prowess
and also his dominance was at 145. that
that's that's hit 140 so
again he's won one fight at 155. and he
looked the best he's ever looked at
eddie alvarez he was
you know and again we got you you got to
take the comments so many years ago
it was so many years ago it was also an
older eddie alvarez and that was his one
win at 55
you know so it's when you break it down
and you take out your bias of how
special economics you're like [ __ ] man
what was i thinking
all right i'm gonna start a rumor right
now could you beat the [ __ ] out of jake
paul
in what mma it would last 30 seconds
i'll choke him unconscious boxing
yes i could be yes i was a golden gloves
champ were you wait
yeah and what about a and and do you
right now is logan a better boxer or is
jake
i would say you've got jake but logan's
just got a little more size
logan has size i think jake's doing it
for he
he wants an extra career in boxing and
logan's doing it
for the payday and just to prove that he
can do it like he like even with the
floyd stuff he's like it's [ __ ]
stupid i'm fighting this guy like i
can't believe like we're living a
simulation
that was he's like i have no business
being dude yeah yeah yeah but and he
acknowledges that reads it and and
realizes how insane it is he's like this
how [ __ ] crazy the world is
yeah like i because i'm famous from
youtube and i have all this fong i can
fight
floyd mayweather you know how stupid
this is insane where
where [ __ ] uh jake is like no i can
beat these guys
i deserve to be here i can beat these
guys and he's gonna learn when he fights
woodley i think it's gonna be
a different animal right yes is that a
huge jump is that a huge
big talent wise the biggest jump huge i
mean you're talking night and day
that's that's like going from open mics
to [ __ ] playing at mad square garden
because you're dealing with someone
who's a real legit striker correct
who's been striking out wild card at the
highest level since what 2007
yeah you know and knockout artist in the
ufc and
ufc hall of famer like it's just a
different animal for him he's going to
find out like it's
there's levels to the game like fighting
just like stand up you can't just
you can't jump the levels like like if
this is mario you're not going to king
koopa
dude you got to go through the [ __ ]
you know that first i
just imagine that first he's out there
and that first jab where he doesn't even
he can't even move his hands he's like
and he's gonna be like got it correct
yeah okay so i didn't get to change
that's gonna be all night
the guy can't do that all night is the
jab
and i'm gonna ask a bunch of dumb
questions to somebody who's never fought
before they'll go ahead
is the jab when you get hit with the jab
is it almost like frustrating
where you're like it stings you're like
[ __ ] because it doesn't hurt
does it almost like
is it almost like a little pink i mean
like it bothers you
and then it doesn't i think after a time
it does but it's
you know it's just there to set other
things up so you're like all right
all right and you're just waiting for
the big boy right yeah yeah dude i uh
i i pulled a video the other day of me
sparring with my son with jacob yeah
hilarious how's he doing by the way
yo he's okay is he he's still out here
you wanna hear bizarro world
yeah so i'm coming out i come i'm i tell
him i go i'm coming out for the week
i'm going to crash at your place i'd
love to hang with you and he goes well
i'm going to be out of town in new
mexico
he's working on a netflix show okay and
he goes why don't you so he got another
gig after coming central yeah he goes
why don't you just crack
so i'm crashing at his place driving his
car
hilarious you know what he said to me
don't [ __ ] my stuff up first of all he
goes for i washed my sheets i'm like
i appreciate that dude i didn't even
need that mental image yeah
but he goes don't snoop in my [ __ ] which
what's the first thing i did when i got
there off dude i'm
i'm a super snoopy i'm the snoopinest
[ __ ] you hell yeah
one thing i learned from him he's
spending a lot more on
shoes than i thought he was love it yo
this dude you sneak your head
holy it's a dicey world there's like a
he
there was like a lot of like a red
they're like lobster
some kind of like how much did you spend
oh were they the dunk lobsters
yeah oh dude he dropped a cr either
somebody hooked him up a plug hooked him
up or he dropped some
serious cash okay bring those up gin
okay lobster dunks
that's they're very expensive listen man
i don't do anything without kratom
stand up podcasting working out i'm
always on kratom but not just any kratom
the best kratom
that has 100 satisfaction guaranteed or
your money back i'm talking about super
specio
that's right that's what i use and
kratom is an all-natural
herb related to the coffee plant that
has been used in thailand
forever forever
helps boost energy relieves stress
enhances your mood
helps my brain when god knows i need it
super specio
has only one ingredient we're talking
about pure kratom leaf that's right
super specious helps you feel good
without feeling impaired
all right again 100 satisfaction
guaranteed or your money back if you're
looking to try kratom
you can trust my boys at super specio
all right
try kratom get 20 off your entire order
go to getsuperleaf.com
fighter that's getsuperleaf.com fighter
promo code fighter
for 20 off your entire order you know
who's always
been there for me credit karma credit
karma has always been there
to help me make better financial
decisions and now they want to help out
even more with credit karma money spend
account you can be rewarded
for good money habits all right credit
karma money is a brand new checking
account where you can win
cash reimbursements for making purchases
when you use
credit karma money debit card you can
win daily instant karma purchase
reimbursements on up to items up to 5
000 buckaroos just pay with your debit
card if you win
you'll be notified on the spot and your
instant karma cash will be added back
into your spend account all right open
your fdic insurance spend account for
free
there's no minimum balance requirements
no overdraft fees
and free withdrawals from a network of
over 50 000
atms all right credit card money
progress starts here right now visit
creditkarma.com
win money to open your free account and
start winning instant karma go to
creditkarma.com
win money to sign up for free and start
winning instant karma
that's credit card dot com slash win
money instant
karma is sponsored by credit karma no
purchase necessary exclusion in terms of
life see rules banking services provided
by
mvp bank incorporated member fdic
maximum balance and transfer limit
supply
so i go what what are these and he goes
don't worry about that
and i said daddy could sell those and
get a lot of cocaine if it's back in the
day i said
what that's what is the red ones right
there this one
yep they're so sick so
i said to him i go where how was the
deal because i found a guy a plug
and he's letting me pay him off monthly
oh interesting
is he charging interest and i go so you
don't get
how come you have the shoes he goes no
he said he trusts me i'm like this is
the dumbest
that's the dumb shoe plug just like hey
dude here's your shoes back
i wore them on seven appearances and
here's your shoes back so
but he's got and he's he said i'm paying
the guy a hundred dollars a month
and he's letting me keep he's gonna pay
him a hundred dollars a month for about
three years for those
no i mean how much are they wait look on
stockx
are you for real nike is that what he's
spending they're a few grand man for
sure get the [ __ ]
for those shoes sorry jacob
are you serious yeah man now do you have
a pair of these i do not have a pen and
you i want some though
the i can't believe that that
pair of with a with a rubber band around
the top
not the purple his or the red they're
red i know it's not showing up though
what is your what is your like your holy
grail yeah
i have them i have the the yeezys the
nike yeezys the
the kanye west that they don't make
anymore those my most ex those are
probably my
most valuable shoe those or scroll up
chin
there you go yeah
twenty eight hundred what size shoe does
you wear eleven and go to size this chin
where it says all
wait a minute see all this is awesome
and then scroll down to eleven and a
half chin i think the 11 is the highest
it goes no it's not
oh 34 3 400 there you go
because more people wear eleven half
they do eleven god
you've been paying for quite some time
sorry jacob
well here okay but if that's his thing
you know yeah
but yo man the next time he asks for
money i'm gonna be like yo why don't you
lobster claw you know yeah once you
[ __ ]
sell those lobsters and pay your rent
huh yo he just got nothing he has to
worry about is getting jacked on the
street for those
so i asked him i said what's the deal
with your shoes are you
nervous because you get some pricey
shoes and he goes no man
i go why not he goes i'm always i always
carry a knife i'm like to do
dude i mean people are robbing you don't
have knives yeah rocks
it's not the 1940s this isn't especially
in l.a yeah dude dude they're rolling up
with a [ __ ] knife you think they're
coming up with
some steel pipes i'm going to get
yesterday and just [ __ ] give him up
bubba yeah there's no
and he was like first of all he was like
a knife and i'm fast i'm like are you
faster than a speeding bullet
you're going to crease your lobsters
running away
i would like here you go and then put it
away i'll take i'd run with them so i
don't crease them dude
that's a real sneaker head move that's a
flat foot you know what's funny is if
a couple weeks ago was the first time i
was ever on stage and i sent you a
picture of like those kind of
rust colored yeah those are sick
and i was sitting on the stool those
cork air maxes
what what would you send me a picture no
these were the cork ones that i sent
um the other ones i i forget what kind
they were i got a picture
but i i it's the first time i've ever
been on stage sitting on the stool
with my foot on the stool and thought oh
i'm creasing my shoe yeah and i took my
and i stuck my legs out straight yeah
yeah i was like wait i'm not creasing
this [ __ ]
yeah dude i have you
noticed the difference in the crowds
that have been coming to see you
uh energy-wise energy-wise for now my
first sets in l.a are this weekend so i
don't know
la's different than the rest of the
country yeah but as far as like
you know i've done a ton of florida
arizona [ __ ] texas
boise we're gonna teach you about boise
which was amazing those crowds are
and especially during the pandemic
people were so grateful to be out
because the people that
either vaccinate or for whatever reason
you know could come out
they were just so grateful there was
something to do so the crowds have been
they've been all home runs
it's amazing i keep telling it almost
doesn't feel real it's like
yeah that joke's not that funny yes i'm
telling you let's pull it back a little
let's take it easy i need a good scale
you guys just haven't been on the house
yeah about six months last night at the
store
the roast battle was right next to the
o.r and it was just
it was like you would have thought
people were being lit on fire yep
it was so loud but it i hadn't been on i
hadn't been on
stage there since last february i hadn't
been on stage there since jeff passed
away
and it was really i think that's the
first set i've ever done on stage
at the store without him the door at the
at the
keys yeah it was really i didn't until i
walked off stage i was like
oh there was no jeff was it weird that
none of the like normal guys were around
by normal i mean like you know the guys
yeah
no because man i've been through a bunch
of different incarnations of that place
i think you're you've been there well i
know right
so i've been through a bunch of
different ups and downs and ebbs and
flows
so you've been through it before and i
understand that that's just kind of how
it goes and it's definitely a different
energy there
it's definitely so good at energy and
emily's running it now
great energy dude great energy that's
not a no it's not a
different doesn't necessarily mean bad
you know i agree yeah it's just like
yeah it's just a different type of
energy it felt really good man
and i and i love that or i
i love that right now there's no there's
no place better yeah i love that room
the main room is maybe my toughest room
in the country
really why so it's my own
thing it's my own you sprayed some [ __ ]
in there
yeah well that's how i'm at the improv
like when i first started the improv was
the only one that gave me spots on this
time so
there's a lot of nights i ate [ __ ] in
there so when they asked for like my
availables i'm always like
you know there's like this weird thing
i'm sure it's like for a quarterback
throw an interception at like green bay
then you
go back the next year you're like oh
[ __ ] that pick today
damn it dude still out there yeah just
it's just nothing to do about it
i i actually have as far as bombing
i have a real short memory yeah good
quarterback
because the good ones do yeah man
because i learned a long time ago that
bombing isn't bombing yeah it's it's the
wrong word it's
yo man you we're not musicians we don't
get to
practice our song in a studio for six
months
no sure if i'm a musician i can practice
six months and i know it's gonna be a
hit and then i put it out
yeah dude we got it with an idea yeah
and you're just like well here we go so
that's why i don't agree uh granted i
hold louie in the highest regard but
when he says oh you gotta bomb ten
thousand
ten thousand times before you get good
it's like maybe you weren't good at the
start dude yeah yeah maybe it just
weren't very good
maybe it took you ten thousand to get
there dude you know
if you ever thought about that like
don't push that on the rest of the
comics
you gotta bomb ten thousand times where
you get good in my head i'm like oh you
weren't very good to start i did bomb
for
quite a while ten thousand maybe not
only ten 000
senses 10 000. i did bomb like now i'm
sure he's exaggerating but
still dude i watched brody and joey and
i bombed back to back to back for years
10 000 though no not 10 000. because any
other line of works like dude you can
[ __ ] up ten thousand times
and then after that you get good i hate
to tell you any other line of work
you're not getting
no you don't get you're like two
thousand hours you're not getting to
500. no yeah you're like hey
you're not good at this yeah this is not
yours if i struck out 10 000 times
before i got a hit
yeah dude if my kid struck out a hundred
times like baseball's not for you dude
by the way yeah but lucy k said ten
thousand yeah i [ __ ] get that and
that was his path
that's not yours yeah he should have
quit yeah he should probably quit but
thank god he didn't because it worked
out but
he's the exception i mean maybe that's
the thing maybe he was so upset he was
like i just got to start jerking off in
front of people
i mean
[Applause]
maybe i just need to start jerking off
in front of people maybe that'll make a
better
relief by the way i have to tell you
jerking off
in front of somebody else unless that's
the person that i'm having
like unless that's what we're doing
together sounds terrible sounds
even if they're into it sounds awful i
just i would be super
self-conscious what my face looked like
like drinking
his body just the whole thing is a
nightmare yeah jerking off in front of
somebody to me has never
been no even if they're smoking hot it's
like well if i'm here with my pants down
yeah you're with your pants down
why am i in this corner you're in that
corner yeah why don't we do what this is
made to do because i can do this without
you here
yeah yeah this is all the time without
you here yeah why am i doing now you're
watching me yeah yeah
you know what kind of psychopath you
have to be to have something loose where
that gets you off that's not it for me
at all
no hard path and like like and i'll tell
you something
obviously times change as you get older
because i would tell you something right
now uh this is how old i am man
i'm this is uh my ideal threesome right
now
would be like my wife and i [ __ ] and
somebody else cleaning up the house that
would be nice do you know what i mean or
somebody else doing it can you go to
like cleaning me up so i guess yeah yeah
can you
that's like i told beth i said we're
officially at an age where if you were
like i want to [ __ ] all night i'd be
like that sounds
terrible ah awful all night no my night
of a threesome would be
me and my girl have sex and then the
nanny take puts the kids to bed yeah
that's perfect
i don't have to do it no man but i'm
done like a third person seems like
a lot of extra work in a lot of a lot of
you know
the a lot of i'm i'm pressure pressure
expectations yeah like i i don't have to
navigate this
this isn't a porno i have no idea what
i'm doing i i just need to focus on this
vagina 100
this is the vagina that i'm struggling
over here
i don't need i don't think i'm hitting
this one out of the park
let me focus over here yeah and not only
that like i don't know yet the
same the 10 000 000 bomb rule yeah and i
don't need to bomb more than once doing
this
and the i find i think vaginas are
different than
dicks because most dicks like when you
ask a guy what do you like
you're in the one there's like three two
three but you don't have to guess too
much
you know what i'm pretty up front with a
woman you can either
find somebody who's like yeah i like it
slow
and steady or punch me in the face just
like what the [ __ ] you went
i don't know which one to try then bauer
from the dodger says what'd you say
yeah yeah yeah that dude what was he
thinking yo
you know you're in trouble this is when
i'm i think
without them saying anything they know
something we don't because they took
all of his jerseys out of the store and
they and
they cut the bobblehead night yeah but
but here's the thing they know something
but that obviously we we're not getting
all the information
but what's what makes me go huh they
know more than we do because
if it was just like hey these are the
facts this girl came over
he choked her unconscious i had sex with
punched her in the face these are the
texts
he's never playing again but for them to
go all right let's look into it
seven day suspension hey let's extend
the seven day six
and i know he's a [ __ ] damn good
pitcher yeah but there has to be more to
the story that they haven't just
like been like all right yep he's
[ __ ] done there has to be something
more to it
do you know it's complicated i think i
think what it is at the end of the day
they didn't know
him but they gave him a ton of money
three year 110 mil i don't know how much
there's got to be a morality clause so
i bet you he i don't know he's not
scared he's not seeing all that he wants
you all that much he can't punch a girl
in the face and get 110 mil from the
dodgers probably not hard pass but i
think
what honestly keeps them from cutting
ties
is just dude it's sports and
can he help us win so let's not cut the
ties
yet correct cause he's a [ __ ]
superstar oh top 10.
yeah we know uh aaron hernandez remember
there's like man he might get off
there's rumors that the raiders are like
yeah we'll sign him yeah that makes
sense
dude when when the patriots and i'm a
patriots fan when they were lining up
hernandez and gronk
i'm sure if defenses were like well what
the [ __ ] because they had hernandez in
the backfield something
slot h-back yeah and you were like what
are they handed the ball off to him
sometimes yeah
like what are we doing with these two
freaks who could line up wide who could
who can also block unstoppable and now
they're one of them is in the [ __ ]
background i think of hernandez at
university of florida where that teba
who's arguably the best college football
player of all time that tebow hernandez
they also had homeboy uh what's named uh
percy harvin too oh jesus just
unstoppable dude
that's interesting you say best football
college football player of all time
i mean it's hard to make an argument
against that you won two right
one two heisman's yeah anyone one title
and a yeah one title
two heismans did you go three or four
years
on four four yeah but you look at you
look at the stats compared to others
like jesus christ dude
yeah i don't know the stats are nutsos
at quarterback
is he going to make you are you on board
with him playing for the job
110 because what they're doing i've and
you know people give him [ __ ] but
with urban urban meyer and tim tim is
like his son
yeah so they they tim could have been
playing the nfl this entire time if he
would have just
dropped the ego and switched and played
tight end and so finally he's been on
the league he's like all right i'll play
tight and especially
now that urban meyer is back so you know
what by signing tim tim is bulletproof
you can
throw all the hate you want him in
social media it does not but he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he doesn't see it he doesn't
care
he'll answer all your questions he'll
handle all the [ __ ] that's what he's
born to do
so you have the no one draft pick who's
gonna you know it's a learning process
in the nfl
so it takes all the pressure off him tim
can handle all of all of it
because it puts the tebow questions at
the forefront yep
tim's the focus though it's actually a
habit that's actually
really smart tim's like you have to be
able to
tell trevor lawrence and this is why we
got him here right now oh that's the
first i bet
that you know he has to still make the
team right you know just make the 52-man
roster but
before they even sign they went to
trevor lawrence like here's the plan
to take pressure off of you this kid's
gonna handle all of it for you man yeah
he doesn't care about starting
throwing touchdowns no that [ __ ] you do
what you gotta do to get ready for the
season
let him handle the media he was like yep
i'll do it you're gonna let your kids
play football
100 yeah what if they wanted to get into
ufc no
that's i mean there's nothing to do if
they want to do it but
you're you're one of your
sons has more muscle tone than i do yes
both of them i'd say
the one-and-a-half-year-old and the
five-year-old the five-year-old is is
definitely as i give credit to their mom
yeah i give credit to them definitely
bigger legs a five-year-old yeah i'm
like oh this is a huge calves
a huge cat but my thing is is like if
they play pop one or whatever he's like
he's gonna sign up for this super
competitive soccer league like if they
have the gift of it yeah run with it but
if they're just like middle tier players
no no bubba this ain't any the juice
ain't worth the squeeze no
you're not getting ct just to be a
[ __ ] rudy on this team like
we're gonna figure something else out
would you so for me
i always jacob played baseball and i
loved it because
you have to worry about anything not a
thing there wasn't now
i loved like trey we he was on a couple
of traveling teams and
it was always funny when there was that
one kid on the other team i remember
jacob showed up we were just they were
playing this one team that they had some
bigger kids and um
you always go up against that one team
where jacob was like does the pitcher
have a mustache yeah a different level
where you're like yeah and yeah and he's
puerto rican yeah is he my age i'm like
i think so yeah that might be his family
and that yankee scout over there not
here for you no
no yeah yo he's there for that
eight-year-old puerto rican who's
throwing 98 miles an hour there was a
kid
legit yeah so he's on the mound and
jacob i guess maybe it was 10 or 11 at
the time
and he's on jacob was a maybe he was
second up
and the kid shakes off a sign and i'm
like okay then he shakes off another
sign i'm like how many pitches does this
[ __ ] kid
he's 11. he kept shaking things off
but he was throwing gas and so
that kid should stay in baseball and
jacob should work in entertainment
it's exactly what yeah but even with
jacob working in entertainment i guess
he's behind the scenes
yeah but if you want to be a comic or
like an actor that's where he'd be like
ah [ __ ] dude
because you know how hard it is like
it's a nightmare man when my daughter
she was young and she was she's doing by
the way
say no more it's a it's quarantine has
been
the worst for people like that the worst
really and
having moved out of uh la it's been a
which you moved to
oh no me i moved out oh yeah so she's
still here you're out there
not being down the street has been a
real mind [ __ ]
um i moved her into my brother's
building so he can run and check on her
but like
you know what man i for people like that
like depression
suicide all that stuff is through the
[ __ ] roof when the pandemic that's
what they didn't take in
consideration when they locked everybody
down the the
like this would be better yeah she was
like the aaa meetings online don't work
for me
no because i don't have to be present
nobody should know me accountable yeah
you just
okay check in and then put on mute and
do whatever the [ __ ] you want to do
you know dude it's interesting that you
bring that up
i because we're obviously in completely
different
spaces with our kids mine are like you
know big kids big problems little kids
smaller problems
um but i constantly look back at like
raising them and like for whatever
reason you try to pick a is this the
spot is this the spot yep
and it dawned on me that like there's so
many
look you s you're gonna say something to
one of your kids
that has a profound ex like effect on
the rest of their lives
and you're not gonna know it at the time
you have no idea like you know the
reason
one of the reasons i wear hat is because
when i was 12 i was washing dishes
in the kitchen and my dad just walked
through the kitchen and he was like
and i just remember him saying man you
have a big forehead
and then the next day i was like i'm
wearing this [ __ ] hat yeah and i wore
a hat
i just wore a hat yeah right but he did
when i told him that story he did the
podcast
he has no idea he was like i don't
remember my dad did the same thing he
had we had this like a napoleon ice
cream man that was like chocolate
vanilla strawberry
it's sandwich no the there was like an
actual like a tub it wasn't a it was in
a box of ice cream
i used to eat all the uh vanilla and
strawberry off the chocolates for nazis
so um he would that was his favorite ice
cream i remember
i came home from school i was probably
in fourth grade and i couldn't wait to
eat i was eating it
and he must have came home from work and
he had the same thought he liked the
same flavors he had the same thought
like
oh i'm gonna get home and eat this ice
cream well i ate all of it so he's like
he comes and the
the thing's empty again he's he you
don't remember him
i remember like it was yesterday he
comes home i'm just laying on the couch
watching [ __ ] tail spin or some
[ __ ] that kids watch
and he goes where's the ice cream
michael what do you mean he goes where's
the ice cream like
oh i ate it and he goes you pig and then
that gave me
uh like body sticks with you right yeah
it's so crazy that way to go dad
has something but you wouldn't be here
today if you grew up feeling good about
yourself no true
um by the way you picked the two
professions
that like if anyone was like did brendan
feel good about himself i don't know he
picked one job where he got punched in
the face
he kicked another yeah he picked another
one where he got on stage in front of
strangers and tried to make him laugh
and
danced like a monkey yeah nightmare yeah
he had some issues yes yeah
yeah yeah dude you picked the two jobs
to feel
terrible about yourself physically and
mentally so yeah yeah crazy
yeah yeah but i thought about that man
and
so when i because i started to feel
really guilty
makes sense like i watch the that show
intervention i watch all of them
and it's on vice now the new ones are
invited i think
you watch those and you see like when
you have a kid or
a spouse or somebody who has an
addiction
the whole family has an addiction yeah
maybe not to drugs but
they're enablers or the whole family's
suffering like a
[ __ ] i always look at my girl
can you imagine if tiger boston had an
addiction
she's like no i can't it'd be a [ __ ]
nightmare dude and i go i'll tell you
right now i'd be an enabler
i'm enabler now i am like my kid asks
for something he probably shouldn't have
it i give it to him
dude so all they don't have that in me
all they would tell me is
you can't give her money you got to not
give her money you can't give her money
and even
yo i one of the first things she said to
me when we picked her up at rehab was
you got to stop lending me money
you can't lend me money anymore but yo
when she calls and that's my baby girl
and she's like i just can't
make rent done paying
there's zero percent chance zero now the
experts will tell you that you're you're
making it worse for it yeah and just hit
rock bottom like i
i get that but as a parent i i don't
i don't have that in me to let them hit
rock bottom uh
my mental image of her on the street not
happening trump's
anything else you can tell me and they
would say what about your mental image
of her dead
and i was like but what if me putting
her on the street leads to
results and that's what all the parents
say on it and so and then what they will
say is
if you don't put her on the street it's
going to end there anyways
right and so tricky it's tricky right
because dude why is it always in canada
it's always in canada all the invention
every single one's in canada now
and the eighth eventually every single
one's in canada i mean maybe there's
maybe there's a lot i mean if i was in
canada just in the cold i might just sit
around and drink and do
yes man it's i mean it is a
nightmare when you watch those
interventions it's a
nightmare dude did you i can't imagine
having a
kid on meth did you read about like in a
lot of the
rivers in america that the trout the
fish are getting addicted to meth
because people are dumping it down into
the toilet oh wow
so they have methy trouts oh damn
drought trolling
yeah the trouts are [ __ ] just ripped
you know the clean the bottom of that
river is clean but
they're cleaning up but those are just
jacked no teeth just
sweat i see that all the time when we
watch intervention someone's on meth or
something like i tell you what
meth is tempting man cause everybody's
shredded i did it one time
oh you did meth one time wow one time
[ __ ] yeah dude so well i didn't know it
was meth i was in
i was in um san antonio and i was with
some buddies
and he was like i'm getting coke and i
was like this was around the time and i
was kind of dabbling in it just to see
if i was gonna like it or not
and um so he brought it back and he was
like the guy said this is really speedy
and i was like okay and i took joke who
describes that it's real this one's
really
but like not like that was an alarm not
like as euphoric but just like yeah
yeah right that's like well i don't i
didn't know enough i got this from this
drug dealer the drug dealer says it's
really
speedy oh this probably laced with meth
dude i but i was too young yeah yeah
give me that thing yeah so we we cut a
line and i hit it
and my nose burnt in a way you know
what's up
well then but then i was like maybe i
did it wrong chasing the dress cut
another lie oh wow good for you
so this is how i know meth people don't
look great
so we were out at a strip club later
that night and when you're messed out
man
i think you think you look sweet you
think you look like [ __ ] tom cruise
but you're just
a sweaty you know that thin layer of
sweat
yeah you look like val kilmer in [ __ ]
tombstones and every part of your body
you touch is a little
damp you know what i mean so it's not
the hot sweat
no dude it's a clammy zombie sweats i
had
multiple strippers and i was like can i
get a dance they were like
no and i was like well i must look
pretty
and those girls need money yeah i must
like hard pass but they must they need
money for their meth
and they didn't want any part of my math
yeah they were like man you're sweaty
[ __ ]
yeah we don't want any piece of that
they led me out the back door
i mean you must have been met the [ __ ]
out yeah she didn't have like spots and
[ __ ] i was yeah when they show those
people on intervention it's like dude or
with the swords
spot the sores all over their legs and
like
i don't know how it gets there dude dude
the stores
are like any time and you do like if i
was doing like if let's say protein
powder was like give me sores on my legs
i'm like oh is that a sore yeah from
what from your protein powder like oh
well i gotta
stop the protein powder yeah are you
talking like once i got six months in
this is what gets me doing i'm not dude
four years later and you're still
[ __ ] with it you know good meth must
be by the way
can i just say that first picture
doesn't look great do you know what i
mean pre-meth
that one no there's argument four years
later she actually enhanced her love
but look at homeboy look at [ __ ] the
nightstalker the the far
right one chin this guy yes
yeah dude that is a i mean that's a
zombie from the walking dead
that's legit if you were like that's a
white walker that yeah that is
legit zombie but if you told me hey
there's something that you're doing and
you walked into a doctor and you're like
i have this open
sore on my face like it's a wound and
it's not healing
that's how addictive meth is yeah and
all the power picking at it all day
and i still look in the mirror like you
know
i'm gonna go get some more it's kind of
a gradual i love how they
you see how skinny like i'm jealous
that's me on the left i want to look
more skinny on the right
and by the way now it's the only
tempting thing for me when i hear people
say
you look kind of messy i now i know what
they mean
because i'm not that far from the dude
you're pretty far from me
i'm not that far from that dude right
there dude look at his
[ __ ] knees also diet coke daddy
just drink the regular coke bubba the
sugar is the least of your concern
gary busey looks great
i mean fun you know thick boy on the
left meth on the right
but that is on the left that's like
that's dude
he's a fireman like this is a
firefighter yeah right
there on the right and this is also dude
i don't
if i did all the meth in the world i
still wouldn't wear my hat that way
like you just can't where you had that
no that is unfortunate that
that for sure the diet coke too you
think
i'll go with diet man i want all the
sugar but yeah dude i that's by the way
that's like
i really got seven lens like is really
this is where you're cutting back
this is where you draw the line the
sugar in coca-cola there was a homeless
dude who used to hang out in front of
the comedy store
and i remember i bought him a a hot dog
once
and i gave it to him and he was like nah
i go you don't want this he goes nah you
know what's in hot dogs those things
will kill you i'm like
you live in a box bro bro this isn't the
first bad decision you've ever made
like i saw you eat a shoe you wanna eat
a [ __ ]
hot dog yeah who's telling you that the
guy that you're talking to who's not
there oh you gotta
fall off your toenails last tuesday you
want to eat this [ __ ]
frank you out of your mind he's all yeah
i am dude
yeah i am here with some crew revenge
sure they shut the ac i feel like in my
method they barely turned it back on so
thank god
i was about to die okay so sasha baron
cohen was being sued for
his this is america prank with
the uh politician
more and he was the one who
was being portrayed as a pedophile
because there were
rumors of him paying underage girls for
services and the guy in alabama yes yeah
and sasha barry cohen pretended to be an
anti-terrorist
uh israeli i don't know what the
official term was but he pretended to be
a guy
and got him on interview to make him say
a bunch of stuff
do things that made him sound kind of
pedophily
after the movie came out he was sued for
yeah kind of pedophile e not full on
yeah but so you see him for a ninety
five minutes yeah ninety-five hoping to
settle out but they gave him nothing huh
yeah he won the judge said that the
first amendment protects him
in this case if you're suing for nine to
five what are you hoping for
i mean within this i mean sasha brancon
has money
for two mil yeah i mean i would like 90
come on because all right one
billion dollars to just like all right
take how about a million yeah
that's fine yeah that's cool i'll take
that yeah but by the way like
how about just don't be a pedophile yeah
but even to be linked to
that that's where the joke came from
yeah that's where sasha bancone that's
where the
whole bit came from yeah like you're the
one with these [ __ ] the
dark cloud of pedophiles i didn't date a
15 year old yeah i don't have any of
that in my [ __ ] resume bubba i gotta
tell you man like there's so much to
that
so in porn today you know people are
calling each other daddy and
yeah i can't think of a word i'd like to
be called
less in bed like if you call me well if
you're a real dad
don't call me daddy yeah if my girl call
me daddy like i think my son called me
that
my kids call me that i'm i'm going i'm i
am my dick will go
soft i'm sliding out almost immediately
directly out yeah there's no way it'd be
triggering
that i didn't never understood the
spitting on each other one either like
you don't need to spit on my dick
i don't need why are you
no man i don't mean yeah where i grew up
like if we spit on each other that's an
aggressive like
sure
sure yeah that's not an eater for you
yeah whatever man
but you are you spitting on each other
no just one way spit
sure okay all right what else you got a
champion
so last name for a porn one was fit last
episode we talked about a huge goldfish
and apparently this is a big issue in
minnesota
because a bunch of locals are taking
their goldfish pets and putting it into
a lake
surprisingly these goldfishes are
growing to be huge
so this is a golden fruit nothing's
[ __ ] dope because
goldfishes tend to release a lot of
terrible bacteria
into the lake which then [ __ ] up the
ecosystem like they're not
cool they're not supposed to be in
regular water
that picture right there that's a huge
[ __ ] look how small that fish's head
is that is a fat
[ __ ] look at that thing they're all you
know it swims like this it can bear
they're all arms diabetes um
i but yeah they muck up the bottom of
the lake with
sediments and different bacteria
uprooting plants and chips
are they eat you can't eat them once
they're in there um i believe
that fishes taste something like similar
to carp so it's not a great fish to eat
it's
considered like junk uh-huh and so what
what what can they do can they
can can you just focus on one type of
fish to get rid of it
uh as of i don't know
actually a lot of people now in this
particular lake are when they're fishing
they're catching a lot of goldfishes
randomly yeah think that they're
something else
they look [ __ ] sweet yeah and
apparently they can live up to 25 years
that's a long [ __ ] day nobody doesn't
if like nobody fishes them or eats them
because they have no predator did you
read about the
shark that they found in the arctic that
was 500 years old
no yo oh is it one of those uh
green whatever green land sharks no they
look
dude they look old as [ __ ] this right
jump look at that yeah it's a green
is it the green yeah it's 512. but they
look 512. yeah and by the way this top
picture this one on the top left
that one its eyes it looks it looks like
one of those felt eyes that you would
make like one of those googly eyes
look at that thing yeah but they look
like a thousand years old dude he's 500
years old do they have picked 500 years
old
you know the amount of [ __ ] that that
shark has seen in 500 years
eaten and look at that thing but does he
not look 500
everybody like he looks 500 he does
his teeth he just looks like one giant
rock yeah it's just like
yeah i'm not scared of that thing damn
and he's still doing the goddamn thing
at 500 years old he's not bananas no you
know
the average well great whites i think
are 80 years
is it 80 70 or 80. holy [ __ ]
but 500 that's how [ __ ] up humans are
they're like oh you're 500 30 years old
i thought the great whites were like 80
were like
crocodiles whale sharks that's what it
is
yeah but this is how [ __ ] up humans
are that poor shark that's 500 who's
like ah god damn it
they found me humans were like oh you're
500 let's see what got him to this let's
[ __ ] kill him now that's it and cut
him open see what's going on see what's
gonna work he's like what the [ __ ]
dude yeah yeah yeah i made it 500 years
let me tell you what's going to make it
and these [ __ ] are going to be like oh
let's get them out of the water and
let's
scrape them off to see how let's cut his
[ __ ] eyes out and see what happens
oh there it is great whites are holy
[ __ ] i know they live
70 years yeah dude but this is the thing
like
sharks alligator crocodile
these are the thing these are the
ultimate
be they they're millions of years old
and they've never had you change
yeah great white's like the ultimate
predator where they stay this think
about that
a crocodile is a [ __ ] have you been
watching shark week
i have not you know i did that show on
there for a couple yeah i stay on shark
week
and i was like they're going around the
materials [ __ ] i mean how many times
can we see the great white jump out like
yeah
do we're gonna do this every year like
it's the same [ __ ] i mean they grab
granted they found this one that's 500
that's whatever but
they are switching up because now it
used to be just like oh
shark attacks and blood and now it's
like actually they're pretty cool
yeah so now there's no cages because
what they realized the last one i was
watching last night
is the cages make them aggressive
because it's like
new to them and so they're in cages and
now the great whites are [ __ ]
swimming fast and trying to get through
the cage
and they're like oh trucks are so
aggressive now they've evolved
the shark week has where they're not in
cages anymore they're just straight up
normal people
swimming with great whites and they
realize that the great whites are chill
they don't view us as food like tiger
sharks great whites
and so it's just the regular camera crew
down there there's [ __ ]
two giant great whites and they're just
chilling yeah did get paul the gelder
was talking about well you know paul
yeah
he was talking about that it it i still
like
i mean yeah
but those shark [ __ ] those people that
are balls deep in sharks it's like
remember you used to see a guy outside
the cage like this guy's a [ __ ]
psycho
but now it's like no it's actually safer
than being in the cage i have an idea
for us
you ready for this yep okay i know you
like shark week
and what is the thing that everybody
tunes into shark week four
they want to see somebody get mold or an
attack right but we never see it right
it's it's always a
uh it's an enactment and those suck
and they're trying to make it real
because they're like it's like how many
people do sharks kill a year
10 15 sure guess who kills
thousands of humans every year hippos
they should do a hypocrisy
dude i would be so what a great host
for hippo week dude thick boy national
jew i mean
it's your boy dude hippo week we have
video of just people getting [ __ ]
mauled by those
dope hibiscus okay and you know when
they show the babies you've seen them
run underwater oh fantastic
they pin their little ears back they
catch pillows
yeah dude you ever seen where the boat's
going and the hippos just like
the hippo's catching on it and the guy
in the boat is like hey can we go faster
it's like a movie
dude if it goes on from master
geographic so there's
gonna listen to this someone in that
board means like hey guys
i know where ball's deep in sharks it's
getting old people are tuning out the
ratings can't be good
how about [ __ ] people running
underwater it's
nuts but not only that here's what else
you get you get funny hippo chasing
[ __ ] boat
they're all fat and dope so you know how
they do this they hold their breath
they fill themselves up with water sure
and they dive to the bottom
and then that's how they bounce up
quickly dude do the one of chasing the
boat
this is what i'll kick off hippo week
with but here's another thing
you know what hippo weak has a shark
week doesn't you know those funny videos
of like
of hippo [ __ ] and spinning their
tails yeah that's great you know you
know i
i can never get tired of that stuff good
stuff so i'm i'm
i have my black belt and sharks i've
been watching shark week since i was
like give me something
i'm set dude look at you tell me how
good shark's vision is underwater one
more [ __ ] time
my man i'm gonna freak out national
jesus that is a multi-ton
look at this [ __ ] lizzo of the water
just [ __ ]
how dope is this and we're not into fat
shaming anymore so it's like
hippos are fat we're okay with it now
but it's good to make like highlight
this thick ass animal dude you're on
that boat
oh dude [ __ ] my now if it's a shark
i'm like [ __ ] you
you're coming this thing will tip your
boat over yeah
tip your boat and now you ever seen a
baby shark look like [ __ ]
you see the baby hippo top five cutest
animals on earth without a doubt
a baby and they're all wet yeah but they
have whiskers
from the jump you're like i like to hug
that dude
come on discovery hippo yo that looks
like something right out of harry potter
that looks like my son
my son boston has always yeah those
little roles
that's the best come on dude okay so i'm
watching a show about baby hippos too
so so far we've got when hippo hungry
hunger hippo is what we'll call the
first show
hungry hungry hippo when hippo's attack
we got a baby hippo
we've got hippo when the hippos fart and
they
wanna shoot their pants yep but here's
the thing is uh shark week we can
control we've realized that sharks
really aren't a problem at this point
yet they keep pushing our face like
they're all dangerous
hippos how many people a year do hippos
kill uh the number one kill but
the number one killer is mosquito
mosquito week what's up
is fun but we kill a ton of people yeah
that's true croc week yep we're only in
africa though that's where it gets nice
yeah cause america were like mosquitoes
what
mosquito did you just say yeah the
number one i watched too much animal
[ __ ] seven hundred
thousand twenty five thousand because
malaria like it carries all that [ __ ]
like it's transferring blood okay
stay i believe that after seeing your
bike snake weak a little bit boring
yeah we're also pretty educated dogs get
the [ __ ] out of my face
i was [ __ ] off a testy fly hard pass
pesky fly sounds dirty yeah yeah i mean
listen you got flies crocodile week hey
i'm on board i'm on board i have to take
it but
harder get like tiffany hash in the
water with crocodiles
kill an estimated 500 people per year in
africa
they 200 super great how many pounds is
that 2
750 kilograms that's that's uh that's
that's my [ __ ] gt3
that's my gt2 my i think my my car is 3
000 pounds
by the way they are incredibly
aggressive
hippo weak dude hippo weeks it's a tough
sell
but the celebrity well where i can get
to celebrities to about season four
right somewhere shark week forever was
just the experts and the sharks
and they're like we are excited you're
referring to the years that i was on the
show correct
now it's like i was watching last night
tiffany hash was swimming with tiger
sharks
they have thor out there [ __ ] surfing
with great whites yeah they're like
hanging off his nuts
we had stevo yeah yeah that's when you
run out of [ __ ]
just discovery discovery next year it
ain't happening dude look at your
ratings i know they suck [ __ ]
yeah we hippo we do six we should
i'm telling you hippo week oh crush is
is a
absolute crusher because you can vary
the programming
and i've had enough by the way i love de
gelder and i love but i've heard i've
seen all their shows
dude i'm telling you i i can i could
[ __ ] name
all of them name all of them i know all
the facts about all the [ __ ] sharks
if you show me
one more [ __ ] great white hippo
jumping out of the water biting the seal
it can't be new material that's all old
[ __ ] but there's nothing on hippos
this is brilliant i think i think we
might have stumbled onto something
i think it's brilliant i do too and
you're ready to host it yeah i'm in dude
i'm not trying to get in the water with
it no save that for the experts no no no
but i mean
i think that's where it's challenging is
like how because you can't really get
close to the hippos because they're so
[ __ ] big and
dangerous like we can't get too close so
that's where
discoveries like i know but what do we
do with them well there's a crew
well when we put the crew in like uh
like some sort of
armor armor i don't know 6 000 pounds
spitballing ideas here dude see what do
you how do you get close to him
i mean i'm not getting look at this okay
this lady's single
to that right now this is i mean look at
her she's like what the [ __ ] hippos
raised by
humans yeah they live in the house nah
that's a pat because by the way oh
okay that's a good idea for about
so i read an article about people that
raised the hippo
until it was i think a year and a half
and then the hippo dragged the man into
the water and ate them and swam away
yeah that's a wild animal dude hippos
crossed so many boxes
they're thick as [ __ ] so you're not body
shaped cute cute baby
cute cute as [ __ ] vegan aggressive
that's popping oh yeah
vegan aggressive which we like
aggressive vegans
progressive vegans is a great name for a
band of coachella god that dude
progressive vegans aggressive yeah hell
yeah i'm on board
listen dude we'll pitch this one yep all
right it's a great idea
next one yeah so some people are
disappointed that richard branson
technically didn't fly into space a few
days ago
he took virgin his company and they
built this
huge aircraft with an actual flight crew
and they flew it
as close as they could to the edge of
space did you guys see it at all
i saw it i watched it above it that's
what's funny so he's in this under
armour like suit and stuff
they're basing some fancy private jet
that just kind of
touches like the very top of earth and
comes down and he's like giving some
motivational speech
while they're coming down he's like i
told you if
if you put your mind to it you can't do
anything like bubba you have
70 billion dollars that's why you're
allowed to fly on this weird private jet
and go to the top of the sky there he is
he's doing that with his veneers and
giving you some fake
motivational speech i honestly
it's hard for me to find something that
i give less of a [ __ ]
about than a billionaire
who is spending his money on almost
going to space do you know how bored he
is
what are you putting all his resources
and going as high as he can in the
private jet that's all that is
that i could give like you're that's
what you're spending years but what's
weird is
these billionaires have nothing else to
do so it's like kim elon musk jeff bezos
are all building [ __ ] to get to
space yeah they're seeing who can get
there first and obviously
like apparently he didn't get there but
so that's all they're doing because they
have no
they're just bored of earth also all
these people sign up for it you know
[ __ ] stupid you got to be the sign up
for that
and even you know i must let you know
he's like yeah people are going to die
trying to get to mars
like you mean the first jedi no no no
listen there's a reason that nothing
lives on mars yeah and by the way
hey instead of like going somewhere else
and making some place that's focused
like something this place is inhabitable
so people can live there
how do we just fix up the place we got
yeah didn't you see total recall
that's [ __ ] that's all it is let's
fix up the place we got and this dude
for me
i like billionaires flexing
in that way i just i'm not saying i was
hoping
something was gonna go wrong
i would have liked that i would like not
i was like like that's the story yeah i
would like the little turbulence like
just to get them to be like whoo dude
it's the same thing when people have
they [ __ ] with steve jobs listen
[ __ ] that guy terrible dad
dude i what he did genius
but as a person to i read did you read
the book
sure did i talk about jobs i remember
getting into like
chapter four and thinking [ __ ] this
where's the chapter on cancer i can't
wait to get to that chapter when i know
he's gonna [ __ ]
for reals once you about four chapters
in you're like what a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
and people like bow down to them like
what i i
complete [ __ ] didn't play well with
others the worst father of
all times and his business partners the
people [ __ ]
everybody every everybody over there
also
was not a programmer just was like hey i
think it'd be dope we've put music in
this little device
and then steve wozniak was like all
right i can do that yeah and then would
do it
while steve went and partied or walked
around barefoot around the city
do you know what bossinak was the
[ __ ] man he's still a lot the
difference is like bill gates definitely
stepped on
next on his way up he definitely did and
a lot of very successful people did
but they all got to a point where they
eventually are like yeah we're giving
back
like phil bill gates say whatever you
want you know his wife gives back yeah
but but he gives that [ __ ] shut the [ __ ]
about covert but yes whatever what
whatever
but he gives back he hit appointment
steve jobs that was never
never neither does that neither does
bezos it's so bezos doesn't play that
game
[ __ ] crazy he could just like donate
like 500 million he's like nah
but his his wife who got divorced his
wife donates like billions of dollars
but jeff never entered 500 million to
him is that like 20 bucks to me
it's like a snickers bar for us
they said he's so rich like if he
dropped like a hundred dollars i was
like oh [ __ ] bent down to get it cost
some more money the time of him bending
down do you know there was
i was on uh so when spade show lights
out was on
and what a great show can't believe they
can't it was a great show his show on uh
netflix aren't canceled canceled too
yeah and so
um let's just talk about the shows that
spade was on they get canceled
there's a lot of them uh i love space
these are [ __ ] and by the way you
don't realize how
you don't realize how talented he is
those sarah like the original
saturday live guys until you're around
them and i saw him
doing the monologue and like being the
captain of the ship like holy [ __ ] this
dude is talented and not only that holy
[ __ ]
if you tell me a lot of his shows he's
been on have been canceled what i would
tell you is
that just means he's been on a lot of
shows correct every show gets canceled
eventually correct
also if that show didn't get picked up
which it probably should have but if
that shouldn't get picked up with him at
the helm
that showing gonna work no there's
nobody like you could have anybody he
was so good he was
so good but and i didn't realize how
talented he was and i was on the show
seven times or whatever it was and when
i was on there every time i was
just blown away how talented you know
what guys like that are really good at
and i will tell you chelsea was good at
this too uh i'm sure what she was really
good at is
look they're there to anchor it right
but
the best shows are when they aren't the
ones who have to be funny
yep that their their egos didn't get in
the way
of how the show was gonna run now they
both
have the capability that if yeah the
chemistry just isn't working they can
take over i can come crush
they always have that but i'm going to
let you and he was genius at that yeah
he would just let you crush
and he would [ __ ] drop in a home run
every now and then
but if the show was going well it was
going well on mine it was like me and
one other comic then the third person
was like this tick tock or whatever and
he didn't book it
and he came in my green room was like
hey listen so there's you another comic
i'm gonna be depending on you and you
and i are going to carry this thing like
let them do their thing but
i'm not expecting much of a man he's
like so i've ripped this stuff written
this stuff
but you definitely chime in i need you
to definitely chime in it's like all
right dude let's do it
but dude to to be that successful
and not only to look if you uh jacob
worked on the show and tom
brunell and brad walker the guys created
the show and buddies of mine
but they would tell you outside of him
being a great dude
and super funny is that his work ethic
monster
work ethic yeah and he's still there
making sure everything's going to go
smoothly no he was great but dude
the difference like you were talking
about the 100 bill we run did a show
once where i
we i i was on the show and i was making
a joke about
on spade show or not space okay i was
making a joke about making it rain and i
just
only had two dollar bills one single
dollar bills in my pocket and i just
threw one on the table just as a joke
it's all i had for effect
and he goes what is that i go it's a
dollar bill he goes i haven't seen one
of those in a long time
i was like oh you probably had you don't
know what that does like
he was like does this buy [ __ ] what's
weird with my kids like they
it's very like they're they're my
parents will send him
cash like tiger cash but they you know
when do you ever see cash especially
even us now but so kids growing up now
it's like cash get the [ __ ] out of my
face
get your card out dude we used to for
jacob one of because
it made we would buy if i was going to
give them 250 bucks
i would give it to them all in ones
because when you're younger
and you just have 250 i think it's a
you're a millionaire
you're just [ __ ] throwing around
you're making it rain in your bedroom
like it was a good time
it's weird too like when i want to
they're dumb yeah when i was a kid when
i wanted a toy right i'd see a
commercial or something
the toys r us in the in my town would
might have it but if they didn't all
right dude
i mean yeah you're not gonna find that
now with amazon
my son see a toy you can go to amazon
click shows up
either that day or the next [ __ ] day
i'm like you have no idea how good you
have it dude
or video games like we'll see of the
commercial for a video game
on his little [ __ ] switch dude you
just you don't go and buy the game you
don't go to gamestop and get a dope game
which was the best experience
ever yeah we literally just click on the
new app
go to the game download it's right there
like you have no [ __ ] clue dude yo
when we grew up so we had very no money
and um
i'm jewish and so when my dad like for
hanukkah
we didn't get sometimes i didn't get
eight different toys i just got one toy
broken up into eight bits i'm like so
this is one wheel i'm assuming that the
next night i'm gonna get another one
yeah yeah legos yeah yeah i was like so
eight legos yeah yeah when we're just
putting this together and it's gonna be
one car
you just give it all at once sucks piece
by piece
yeah what else you got jen there you go
okay so there's a video of the rapper uh
the baby he gets out of his printer and
there are
two kids trying to sell him candy and
they see that
the baby it's a very famous rapper and
they try to upsell him they're selling
gushers and i think fruit roll-ups
and one of the guys say that he's
selling the whole box for two hundred
dollars the other guy says that he's
selling his box
for 400. yeah they're teenagers they're
old enough to know better who he is
but uh basically the baby says here i'll
buy it
one of them from each other
[Music]
he's got a stack of cabbages
you made 400 off that yeah and you sell
them for two dollars yeah
that doesn't make sense no let's count
this first thirty four seconds
what's 34 times two my boy
it ain't two hundred sixty eight bucks
[Music]
[Laughter]
i love him yo he was ready to give them
200.
hook him up but he got greedy but then
he was like how much two dollars how
much in the bag
34. how much is that and then that long
blank's there yeah yeah yeah
he's like six eight dollars my man you
[ __ ] up yeah yeah and now he's gonna
hook you up but
that's a good i always by the way if
there's always somebody who's like hey
out in front of the
grocery store trying to get to
washington today i'm like i don't need
the store yeah like dude just
how much stuff just yeah i i look have
you ever done any kind of cold sales
like that
oh yeah you sell supplements during the
day so that is a tough gig
so if i see somebody if you get the
balls to ask strangers to give you money
i'm gonna give you i'm gonna give you a
little money for me
it's getting high fee what else you got
high for you wow look at you
oh wow bay area stuff all right that's
burial stuff um
there's a festival the cherry festival
and you know those carnival rides
fair rides they kind of mess up every
now and then that one yeah that's the
one we're talking about
check how scary this [ __ ] is dude and
the people that actually helped are
are pretty badass yeah yeah watch so
much
oh [ __ ] that was called the rainbow at
elite garden
look at look at it shake
look at that dude trying to hold the
fence that's the worker
there's another angle that is so
frightening
[Music]
i don't know how the [ __ ] you get off
but see how it's like almost tipping
over a little bit
right there there you go oh that badass
goes up there and all these people that
are
super brave they actually like hold it
and jump on it
[Music]
and it's starting to slow down yeah
i have already i would have pissed and
[ __ ]
already at this point oh my god
okay honest that's basically it bishop
you're at that not that you're going to
be at that carnival but hard pass
let's say you're at that carnival are
you one of the people on the fence
leaning back 100
are you yeah i think so yeah i live for
those and by the way they're gonna need
your pounds yeah they're like hey
you yeah i can't you can't be just this
big guy walking by like
eating cotton candy hey [ __ ] mountain
how would you come over and [ __ ] help
these innocent people like
nah i gotta get i'm gonna go get another
turkey leg you know it's like
now by the way tell me dude because we
just touched on your size
yeah how much bigger you think you are
than the last time i i mean
i wouldn't say bigger because i'm leaner
but stronger yeah
yeah but you both you guys are just
jacked you
me uh uh spell's not jack okay okay
all right i love chapelle but yeah but
would you would you say chappelle's
jacked that's not how i would describe
chappelle he's a head cold so he can't
be here today but
he he called out on a head cold yeah i
was like all right well
uh he looks like he's both i've been
missing
seven years yeah dude that's not that's
like terrell davis with his come on dude
it's the super bowl
yeah get in there get in there i know
you got migraines but get in
get in the [ __ ] get in there so okay
did you tell him
hey i don't need you to come in today
why you feel like you have a head cold
yeah
you should come yeah that's a power move
um i would i wouldn't say he's just he
you know he's definitely he's gotten way
stronger like he's been
315 for five what's your gains right now
like where are you at
i don't know where i really started
because i you know i grew up in gyms
like that
and then i took just a long time off i
was just riding my bike forever and i
still ride my bike but not like i used
to so then
i found this gym zoo culture right by my
house and just got back into it and
so i don't know where i start from but
like i'm the strongest that i've ever
been like ben
425 dead lift 600 600
and for no reason god yeah that was my
next question like
just something to do yeah just something
to do yeah i read books
i read books too but i'm just kidding i
don't really know
just something to do yeah yeah that's
why eric griffin says he goes i see i
see man
you're crazy strong why though yeah
what's he saying to help you on stage
like break this much yeah i don't know
dude it's just some you know
i can do both i have gotten back in the
gym you know you can do stand-up
and be healthy yeah yeah well i
definitely i took about a year off in
the gym which wasn't good because
i got down to my auschwitz weight yep
but um
spine starts showing out the back dude i
didn't realize because you see yourself
gradually yeah
it just doesn't happen overnight i saw a
picture of myself just from five months
ago
and i'm lighter than maybe i was a year
and a half ago but i don't know if i'll
ever put that weight back on dude
because
it took me i'm a naturally thin dude
it took me 12 years to get up to 178
pounds
so when i lost it at my age look like a
baby stegosaurus
yeah dude and i'm not gaining that
muscle back your age is stuff
matthew mcconaughey talks about how you
know he was always with his shirt off
running [ __ ]
and throwing up the texas longhorns and
stuff and then we did dallas buyers club
you know he's the man with the aid so he
lost
all this weight he's like you [ __ ] my
body like he's like i can't get back i
can't get back in my age i can't get it
back no i can't eat it
yeah but dude call up the guy who's
doing the thor's diet and or the rocks
and just do what he's doing
and by the way i don't think mcconaughey
i mean
it's not like he's not doing peptides in
hgh
but just do trt and get the muscle back
mcconnell
also run for governor but what does
peptides do exactly what are that's not
like a
no they they definitely are peptides in
that same family for sure is that more
of a recovery thing
no there's peptides that have uh
testosterone
so would you do peptides and crt or one
of the other uh
you could for it depends what you're
going for how old are you
uh 38.
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're the strongest you've ever been
yeah it seems seems like it'd be natural
what else you got
oh sweet kicks by the way bro oh yeah
these are dope
yeah i've been that by the way the nike
is a rabbit hole that puma did not send
me down yeah
that like i find myself looking for
shoes now
that i just never did that before like
he's been making dope shoes for hot
seconds so it's a
long rabbit hole but there's so many
different like styles i didn't think i
would like this style yeah the air max
those are [ __ ] air max 90s are great
yeah great and especially for like my
age i was like these are comfortable
yeah those are great yeah he was like an
old [ __ ] filipino nurse looking for a
comfortable shoe
anything else chin uh yeah this is a
really cool thing in a qriket match
look at this girl how she recovered this
ball
long off and long
watch oh
how crazy is that don't have a glove or
nothing that's the way i guess that's
cricket's rules
yeah we played as a kid what if she went
out she just
she threw it up and went back in and
died for it
i gotta tell you i've never been so
excited about something i didn't know
anything about like i don't actually
know what just happened but it looked
[ __ ] like dope right
right really yeah those matches though
come on
they can go days like cricket matches
i know it's huge in india and i get it
i mean it's not like it's not like sammy
so hit the ball [ __ ]
500 feet in the air and then she caught
it you know
and then she was all it's pretty
athletic though to have
it wasn't even fast oh my god
dude to have the presence of mind to
throw it back
tap tap and throw it back in yes yeah i
mean it's her job you know it's cricket
i'm just not impressed i don't really
know i thought that was i thought that
was super cool yeah i thought that was
pretty good
maybe like this it's not as impressive
as a baby cow i know this is one of this
supposedly the world's smallest cow he's
a full chocolate
cow no that's the thing so it's like a
dwarf it's like 23 months i think oh
look at those eyes oh it's a mini me
mm-hmm
he has the head though like a regular
account and it's like uh
he's all the top of the small people big
world fans yes exactly why does that
look like a bit like a tiny buffalo well
you have some but that's an appetizer
right there with the honeybees
that guy you know he has the power he
has the power butt too
yeah yeah you know like little little
people have power butts like you've
never seen a flat ass little person
they all have asses for days
it's all condensed so you can't you're
not gonna have like even you know
that type not even asian small people
have flat asses
like even the asian small people just
have [ __ ] you just talking about just
regular asian people
like a lot of hp are flat ass yes yeah
it's just what it is there's a lot of
wiping of flat asses yeah yeah but then
the
the all small people have fat asses dude
i i guess i hadn't thought about that
but that does seem
i've given a lot of thought i might have
to call brad williams he hasn't asked
just be like send me a picture of your
ass yeah
that'd be a weird one he's cheeked up is
he yeah there's no flat ass
small people it's just not it doesn't i
mean it actually seems like a pretty now
that i'm thinking about it it's
absolutely rule it's
constituted is that it oh yeah that's it
wow you got another one it's just a
quick one it's uh floyd mayweather
posting about
conor mcgregor oh i did see that yeah
yeah i didn't see that you all got it
twisted
i mean it is the internet was not nice
to this day
no i ate but you hella mark harley liked
it i know
he he's not who's hella mark harley my
boy
you you mean the guy who i work out with
yeah the werewolf he's great yeah look
at him there he's [ __ ] ridiculous
yeah
this the way that bottom what's this one
with the
that one this one the tiger king no to
the left this one yeah what's with the
that's just the photoshop photoshop
that's tiger can't you say this post is
on america
and shake my head that's his thank you
voices haters will say that's just uh
yadda yadda shake my head yeah he's
great you would love him dude i love
hearing him talk
he's yeah he's great it's unbelievable
he's in costa rica for like [ __ ]
six years way to go did he leave uh i
think he comes back
on monday or some [ __ ] but he's been
there for two weeks
he's he's missed lifting for two [ __ ]
weeks is he which does he train you or
do you guys just work out together we
shall work out together but he'll be
like hey let's do this today like all
right
and has he oh yeah there it is oh
bricktown's
one of my favorite clubs dude i haven't
been there great club
i was the first comic ever to do their
stage and then i went back
to a few months ago one of my favorite
[ __ ] clubs the other thing is is
we got to do is across street from them
is their triple a team yeah which is the
feeder team to the dodgers yeah so they
have oklahoma i forget they're oklahoma
city something but it's they're the
affiliate to the
the dodgers yeah so all their gear looks
like the dodgers but it's
[ __ ] oklahoma city it's my favorite
[ __ ] i'm on board i bought their jerseys
their hats
i'm on board i'm definitely and i'm
psyched to go there uh
like i said i've never been to that club
yeah bricktown is
end of july and then if you're in
nashville
i'm doing my monthly show there which is
more like a
you know the my favorite thing about
that show is i take
somebody who's never done standard
before so say you come out
and he'll do five minutes kyle he'll do
five minutes even though he's never done
stand up that's the point
you never do stand up and so i know
going in you've never done standard
before you you bring in five minutes how
do you
pick them they we book them ahead of
time okay all right and then
they do five minutes we take them off
stage me
and two other professional comics
hunting steve burns punch up their [ __ ]
we punch up their act and then we send
them back on stage that's cool
dude it is so much fun do they remember
the punch
so that's the thing we don't give them
more than six or seven we stay up on
stage with them
it's not kill tony because that's not
really my vibe but i'm not roasting it
yeah you're not mean
no and so it's more like encouraging but
it's fun
it has been so it's cool too so we do
that plus there's a lot i have a lot of
country stars that come down and do a
bunch of
fun [ __ ] maybe easy and then um
and then west palm beach jelly roll dude
yo it's my brother from a thicker mother
so jelly has done this
this monthly show with me every time and
he comes on stage and improvs with me
we've written him some material this
dude is he's a beast they're
super talented and one john have you
sang with him
yeah have you gotten drunk with him yeah
he had
cat and [ __ ] nashville twist dude
we've never seen cat drunk she was
[ __ ] bouncing off the walls dude
i hadn't drank a nice steve and i got
together i was so drunk
he and i got together that night after
not wanting a relationship
oh really yeah you're so hammered you
got a relationship yeah what a beautiful
love story
thank you i don't want to take credit
for it anymore that's that's [ __ ]
jelly roll can't wait for you you gotta
tell your kids that story yeah
we were [ __ ] up yeah he got us so lit
and then you know theo who's you know
he's
he's sober he doesn't want to be around
that stuff i'm not sober
and i like to be around that stuff so my
green room was a [ __ ]
party dude and it was like like uh
what's her
lucy who runs zany's she goes it's so
funny when you go in your green room it
looked like
jelly roll was the sun and you guys were
just planets orbiting around him because
he had this whiskey or it was uh from
the rock yeah
because i forget what it is but it was
fantastic
so he brought that for us and we were
just hovering around just pouring in
one's drink
he was like man you need to tighten this
green room up man like but i don't
though but
this is how i roll it actually is pretty
tight it was so good yeah yeah yeah this
is tight for me dude so he
that's what my green room is like too i
hadn't drank in probably four years
first show i do with him oh yeah yeah he
you can't be sober on jelly roll
it it it is a non-stop and then we just
keep as he told you
he so you know he's obviously big he has
some health issues and he goes
i go wow you want whiskey i don't drink
whiskey bubba he goes i only tequila
because the doctor went up to me and
told me if you keep drinking you're
gonna die
and he goes okay i understand that but
if i have to drink
what would be healthy he told me tequila
i'm like dude that checks out with me
dude
that makes total sense yeah cheers
i've never seen anyone put it away so we
did i
i did he called me once he was like hey
will you get a couple minutes for you
come in and pop and do
a little bit of my music video and i was
like yeah it was right near my house at
santa's pub
yup and i was like yeah i'll come down
dude because man
i love this dude he has got the biggest
heart
the best he's just like yeah just that
big heart of dude
so talented so talented so we go down
we're blowing he sold out to ryman in 20
minutes man oh yeah
so we go down there we're shooting the
video and we're sitting at the bar for
part of the video
and so one of the video part of the
video is a bunch of us are doing shots
and he's taking a pull off of a bottle
of tequila
by probably being drinking half the
bottle yes so
in music videos tequila is water
not in his no why would you my man
no joke took down half of the bottle
and the guy who shot it goes hey
we didn't get that one we got to do this
shot one more time he's all for it and
he was like
okay yeah and but i was like dude
you have six hours left he's like yeah
yeah he didn't get [ __ ] but he can
drink like i can smoke
yeah yeah he's the best it's a non-stop
he uh he's gonna do one of the fight
campaigns
he saw fight committee detectives next
fight company i'm [ __ ] there he'd fly
out for it yeah i know that's why tom
was like yeah if you want to come dude
he's more than welcome
dude the the the only complaint i have
about nashville is the weed
it is is it not good it's not legal so
it means you got to buy
you probably never bought drugs from a
drug dealer no no anybody ever
okay so my favorite my my least favorite
thing about buying drugs from a drug
dealer
is that you had to sit down on the couch
and talk to them for a half an hour
before they would give you
you're like yeah okay let me see you
play call of duty
you know what i mean you're just like
[ __ ] whatever and you're just
you're a baby just give me the [ __ ]
goods and let me
get the [ __ ] out but not and so and the
the weed comes in sandwich bags like i'm
in high school i'm like listen bro
yeah it's not la dude no you can walk in
the basement apple store and get the
best sweet in the world
an apple store is right yeah an apple
store for a week but yeah but i've
enjoyed it man
and guys come check out the shows on the
road um and the guitar stuff
has been going so i just shot an hour
and a half
i was like i'm gonna do every song and
then so i sold out two shows in zany's
and i did every single one of them and i
had like an hour and a half oh yeah
and it just was a [ __ ] the very first i
do a song about a dude with man boobs so
i hired a dude with big titties to dance
behind me hell yeah
and so he was dancing shirtless behind
me and did it in front of one of his
huge tits and did it was some in front
of somebody in the audience
this is not scripted and the guy in the
audience stood up and put the tip in his
mouth
hell yeah and i had i filmed it i'm like
ah that was yeah
yeah but it was the first song i'm like
i can't follow this yeah i do
they're just all down there did a
stranger just lick another dude's son
some tits yeah that's exactly by the way
that's what i said i go bro did you just
suck a titty
yeah he was like yeah double d yeah yeah
double d
you guys
the man's skin is thick that's a fight
club titty remember what was that good
yeah yeah that was meatloaf me yeah
that's meatloaf titty that's right yes
yeah
that's one of those media yeah just just
dude um i am uh
la for shows this uh friday and saturday
eric griffin will be with me on friday
first show is already sold out second
show five tickets left
where's haha's is like uh toluca lake
right north hollywood toulouse lake area
um and then saturday is me and chris de
stefano so chrissy d and myself
will be there saturday shows are at
eight and
ten this saturday meet in the squad shop
and friends
haas in los angeles and then tacoma
washington
end of the month 29th through the 31st
great
washington yeah great club uh chappelle
laces out lacey's and david lucas will
be with me
there and then uh north carolina august
19th
21st la jolla california still waiting
for your girl emily sending the tickets
for the
uh the link to the tickets that's san
diego's
comedy store la jolla august 27th 29th
san jose
september 9th 11th the big boy san
antonio bud light event center september
24th
25th then denver vegas and honolulu
hawaii get tickets
f-a-t-k-z.com or thickboy.com all right
kids
josh love you man buddy always want to
tell you this man you know last year
uh the show went through some [ __ ] with
brian being gone you're the only guy who
stepped up to the plate
so i'm forever grateful for you man
listen to the special place i appreciate
it man and i will tell you this
i i consider you to be a good friend of
mine i'm super close
so zero [ __ ] what other people had to
say or anything like that yep
always any time you know the time yeah
love you man love you buddy
which i get i i promise